Willkommen bei der Podcast-UFO, heute in Askaban. Wir nehmen hier auf und freuen uns sehr, die Mentoren heißen uns auf.
Herzlich willkommen zu der neuen Folge Antenne Asgaban.
Ihr habt auf Twitter abgestimmt, welche Sonderfolge wir zu Folge 103 machen können.
Ihr habt euch gegen Antenne Apu, gegen Antenne Auenland und gegen Antenne Alabastia entschieden, was mich sehr gewundert hat.
Zur Antenne Asgaban, deswegen herzlich willkommen zur ersten Folge von Antenne Askaban, heute mit Florentin Will und Stefan Tietze.
Herzlich willkommen.
Wow, ey, was für ein, wo soll man anfangen?
Wir haben uns speziell für ein Thema entschieden.
Ich meine, man könnte über alles reden.
Man könnte über Zauberstäbe reden, man könnte über Zaubersstöme reden, man könnte über die Geschichte von Hogwarts Zauberstach reden. Man könnte über die Beziehung der verschiedenen Charaktere zueinander und darüber hinaus berichten. Aber 20 Jahre Harry Potter, tatsächlich auch diese Woche wurde gefeiert. Wir sind also heiß im Land. Wir sind lächerlich relevant heute. Mega relevant, so relevant waren wir noch nie, außer die zweite Weltkriegsfolge tatsächlich. Das war Glück. Und das eine Mal, wo wir sogar im Internet mal erwähnt wurden, weil wir die Erdogan-Nummer eingeordnet haben, uns mit Star Wars 3 verglichen haben, und da gibt es einfach einen großen Artikel über uns, wie wir die Geschehnisse des Erdogan-Putsches mit Star Wars 3 in Verbindung setzen, und es klingt lächerlich gut. Es klingt lächerlich gut. Kann ich mich gar nicht so gut daran erinnern? Ja, ich schick mal den Krum. Aber gut, ja, die Sache ist die, Harry Potter ist eine grosse Welt. Ich frage mich, wie weit hat J.K. Rowling vorausgeplant? Weil es gibt ja viele Logiklücken in Harry Potter, da können wir auch ein bisschen darauf eingehen. Heute natürlich, ihr habt natürlich in unserem Best-of, zehn Facts, die ihr noch nie über Harry Potter wusstet, gehört. Es gibt viele Sachen, die falsch laufen. Aber ich dachte mir einfach, J.K. Rowling so, ach wie, ich darf noch eine Folge schreiben, ich darf noch eins schreiben.
Fuck it, Zeitreise, fuck it, Dämonen, die plötzlich irgendwie Seelen aussaugen.
Ich glaube, die hat einfach nicht weitergedacht und dann so, ja, ne, mach mal acht.
Und es sind ja genau acht Jahre, die man auf der Hogwarts bleibt.
Wir stellen uns aber heute auch mal die Frage, Hogwarts ja, aber was dann?
Sieben Jahre. Das stimmt.
Heute ist die Frage, was passiert nach Hogwarts?
Worauf bereitet ein Hogwarts eigentlich genau vor? Was kommt danach? Studium anfangen, doch lieber erstmal ein Volo machen bei Ollivanders. Man weiß es nicht genau, was will man am besten machen? Aber wir können ja erstmal, bevor wir darauf eingehen, nochmal kurz über die Entstehungsgeschichte von Harry Potter reden. Giant Care Rowling ist mit dem Zug durch England gefahren und dann fiel da plötzlich ein, Junge, der zaubern kann, kommt auf eine Zaubererschule. Unter der Treppe? Nein, nur diese beiden Sachen, die ich gerade gesagt habe. Sprechende Schlangen. Alles nicht, nein, nein, nein, das kam alles dann später. Fliegende Autos. Sie hat, wie gesagt, nur diese beiden Gedanken erst mal gefasst. Junge, der zaubern kann, nicht dreiköpfiger Hund, sondern die Zaubererschule. Und dann kam halt sowas wie achtköpfige Hydras, die mit Trollen kämpfen. Und das ist halt spannend. Und ich finde das sehr interessant, weil das sagt so viel über kreative Prozesse aus. Und sie ist halt auch schon eine krasse Person. Die wollte auch nie wirklich ein Kinderbuch schreiben. Und man merkt das ja auch im Endeffekt, die Bücher werden ja auch immer erwachsen. Aber ist denn Harry Potter eigentlich gut? Gute Frage. Also ist es wirklich eine gute Geschichte,
weil Folge, Episode 1
hat nicht wirklich einen Bösewicht,
der Endkampf ist lame, irgendwie, natürlich
die Prämisse ist so cool, einfach weil man sagt,
so geil, als Kind irgendwie zaubern lernen will,
jeder irgendwie, man fusioniert die
Schulwelt, die jedes Kind kennt und diese
fantastische Welt, in der man gerne sein möchte,
also du hast, du kannst dich da total gut reindenken,
du hast nervige Lehrer, du hast erste Liebeleien und so, du hast alles, was in deinem Leben vorgeht, in so einer Zaubererwelt. Ich finde, das hat tatsächlich alles. Also Harry Potter hat, wie ich finde, auch geht es mehr über diese Story, die ja eigentlich nur darum geht, wie wer mit Verlust fährt, kommt mit Verlust klar. Harry, der früh seine Eltern verloren hat und dementsprechend erst mal auf sich alleine gestellt ist und so ein bisschen verloren durch die Gegend wandert. Und dann Batman, ähnliches. Batman wird, schließlich und deswegen der krasse Superheld aller Zeiten.
Aber tatsächlich, das ist einfach die Geschichte und darum entstehen so viele andere Geschichten und das macht es einfach zu einer
guten Gesamtstory. Der erste Film ist aber auch nicht als Film angelegt, der jemals alleine bleiben sollte.
Ja, aber ich finde, was immer geil ist, sind Institutionen. Zum Beispiel bei Star Wars, das coolste sind doch die Jedi.
Aber Film ist aber auch nicht als Film angelegt, der jemals alleine bleiben sollte. Ja, aber ich finde, was immer geil ist, sind Institutionen. Zum Beispiel bei Star Wars, das coolste sind doch die Jedi, weil das ist eine Institution. Da kannst du ausgewählt werden als Padawan, da gibt es dann die coolen Lehrer, die haben eine Bibliothek, ist das cool, weil es ist eine Institution. War Yoda ein cooler Lehrer eigentlich, oder war es eher so, oh nee, wir haben jetzt zwei Stunden Licht, wir haben bei Yoda. Morgen, Herr Yoda. Und wir reden wieder auf Star Wars. Und er er hat so ein Videomanitor reingeschoben und wir gucken doch ein Hologramm. Yay! Ja, Institutionen sind einfach cool, deswegen ist Harry Potter eine tolle Sache. Aber erst mal, wir wollen ja heute so ein bisschen über das Berufsleben reden, ich sag mal Accheopraktikum und darum soll es heute gehen, was sind eigentlich die Berufsauswürste? Deswegen die Folge heute, Accheopraktikum, Hogwarts und was dann? Das ist heute die grosse Folge. Das Tolle ist ja, man sieht ja in der Harry Potter Serie, man sieht eigentlich alle Berufe, die es gibt. Und es werden ja auch Berufswünsche formuliert, Harry Potter möchte ein Auror werden. Wo wir schon bei dem spannendsten Beruf wären überhaupt. Direkt. Das sind halt sozusagen, ich habe es nicht ganz genau verstanden, weil ich dachte immer, es wären so die Polizisten, die Polizisten der Zaubererwelt, aber die gibt es ja. In irgendeinem Endkampf, in irgendeinem letzten Teil laufen die durch dieses Ministerium und zerstören das dann so ein bisschen und dann laufen auch so Polizisten rum, die auch aussehen wie Polizisten, die haben sogar diese Uniform, diesen Hut auf, der auch gar nicht magisch oder so ist. Die haben nur, die haben einfach gesagt, komm, fuck it, ey, die machen wir jetzt, wir müssen nicht noch ein Kostüm überlegen, nehmt einfach Polizisten, scheiß drauf. Ja, aber anscheinend kannst du in der Zaubererwelt auch einfach normaler Beamter werden. Ja, ja. Du denkst, okay, ich habe... Haben die auch eine Pistole, frage ich mich, oder müssen die trotzdem mit dem ähnlichen Zauberstab rumfocheln? Ich habe jetzt sieben Jahre lang Zaubertränke, Liebestränke gebraut und habe irgendwie gegen Dämonen gekämpft und jetzt stehe ich den ganzen Tag irgendwie vor so einem Schalter und pass auf, dass da niemand Radau macht. So, das ist mein Leben jetzt. Aber vielleicht kann man diese so gute Nacktscanner-Sprüche oder so aufsagen. Ich glaube, die Harry Potter-Welt ist die deprimierendste Welt, weil deine Ausbildung so viel interessanter ist als sein Berufsleben. Ganz kurz, lass uns kurz zusammenfassen. Harry Potter will Auro, Hermine Ministerium und Rupert Grinch möchte Ladenbesitzer werden. Und damit haben wir sämtliche Berufe der Reporterwelt abgesteckt. Es gibt das Zaubererministerium, es gibt Auroren und es gibt Ladenbesitzer. Ich wäre nicht Professor Stefan Tietze, wenn ich nicht hier... Ja, und du kannst Professor werden bei Hogwarts, ja. Aber das war's. Naja, du kannst noch andere Sachen machen. Also es werden noch andere Bücher, noch andere Bücher vorgestellt. Beispiel. Drachen zähler. In Teil drei bringt ein illustrer Bus den Harry zum... in eine Bar. Ja, ich weiß nicht mehr genau, wie die heißt. Aber jedenfalls der tropfende Kelch, der tropfende Kessel, der Honig... Tänzelnde Kelch. Tänzelnde einer Bar. Und da fährt er dann Bus hin und da gibt es ja auch einen Busfahrer, wieder Typ und dieser Buschauffeur. Das ist auch zum Beispiel ein Beruf, was wir nicht wissen. Die Drachen vom Trimagischen Turnier. Der Bruder von Ron ist doch sogar so ein Drachen-Heini, der dann die Drachen stemmt und so und dann die train trainiert und dann anfängt, rumzuschicken. Aber lass uns mal auf die Grundlage von Berufsleben eingehen, Geld. Man arbeitet, um Geld zu verdienen. Was mich immer gestört hat in der Harry-Potter-Welt ist das große Problem von Geld. Erstens, wozu brauchst du überhaupt Geld, weil du kannst dir alles herzaubern? Um bei dieser Süssigkeitenfrau im Zug alles zu kaufen. Was für ein Bitch-Move von Harry übrigens. Die Person, die wir mögen sollen, dass die im ersten Teil einfach den ganzen Wagen kauft. Nichts für alle anderen übrig. Erstmal wäre es eigentlich dann logischerweise eine Geschichte, sieben Jahre Diabetes und was dann normalerweise geworden. Ja. Ist es nicht? Du musst nach Hause wieder zurück zu einer Scheißfamilie, weil du krank geworden bist, Harry. Schade, na ja. Ja, gut, aber du hast zumindest abgemeldet, wenn er eine Art Test vom Arzt hatte. Da wird aber schon im Prinzip gesagt, wie das Geld in Hogwarts funktioniert, genau wie in der Echtenberg. Aber können eigentlich alle in der Harry Potter Welt zaubern? Weil es gibt ja Muggel, die können nicht zaubern. Aber die sind eigentlich in der Welt. Aber wenn du ein Kind kriegst und du selber kannst zauberwirken, können dann deine Kinder automatisch auch zauberwirken. Aber Hermine hat doch Muggelelter. Ja, Hermine ist ein dreckiges Schlammblut. Aber wie geht das denn? Auch toll, dass auch so eine Rassismusnummer dann nochmal da angesprochen wird. Herkunft und so, das ist egal, tolle Message. Aber ich verstehe es nicht, wer kann zaubern und wer nicht, kann potenziell jeder zaubern, der auf Hogwarts kommt? Nein, du musst schon geboren werden damit. Aber wer wird so geboren? Das ist zufällig, glaube ich. Nee, das kann nicht ganz zufällig werden. Doch, ich glaube, ich bin mir sicher, dass es zufällig ist. Dass auch in der normalen Bevölkerung ab und zu Leute zaubern können. Hermine hat ja nur Muggel-Eltern. Niemand von denen. Wie wurde die denn entdeckt? Die hat sich, glaube ich, selber entdeckt, weil die so super schlau ist. Hat die gesagt, Moment mal, was ist denn das, was ich da machen kann? Oh, und wenn ich da jetzt ich glaube, das ist einfach die einzige Person,
die Latein gelernt hat in der Schule.
Und dann, ich glaube, wenn du Latein lernst,
bist du automatisch Zauberer, die meisten ziehen es nur nicht durch. Oder sie schreibt so an Doktor Sommer
so, ich weiß nicht, was los ist, ich kann Schlangen
verstehen und irgendwie die Krüge fällen immer um, wenn ich
wütend bin, was ist los mit mir? Aber nun zu meinem Freund.
Wir haben seit zwei Monaten, sind wir zusammen.
Ja, er möchte Nackfotos
von mir, soll ich das machen? Ist eh scheißegal, weil du kannst durch die Zeit reisen, Hermine. Fuck it! Das nervt mich. Ja, aber das ist einfach unklug. Man kann sich darüber aber trotzdem auf. Es ist einfach unklug. Es ist einfach schlecht gelöst von Dr. J.R.R. Just kidding, rolling. Das Ding ist mit ihr aber auch auch das ist ja auch beim Cursed Child, bei dem
neuen Play, was rausgekommen ist, geht es ja
nur darum. Ich dachte, die haben
das eine genommen, was mir nicht gefällt, und
daraus das ganze Play gemacht.
Weil es ist natürlich auch cool,
Zeitreisen sind ja auch wahnsinnig cool, machen wir uns nichts vor.
Ja, aber du machst alles kaputt. Aber in einer Welt, wo eh schon
alles möglich ist und dadurch sämtliche Logiklücken
entstehen, dann noch diese eine
Konstante, die noch da war, das Prinzip der Zeit zu brechen, macht wirklich alles kaputt, leider. Ja, Zeitreisen ist einfach das Problem, weil es ist immer cool, aber es ist immer schwer ein Ende zu finden, weil es gibt keine Probleme, die Probleme sind leicht gelöst und am Ende ist dann eher das Zeitreisen selbst das Problem. Und da denkt man sich, ja, was lösen wir denn jetzt eigentlich? Vor allem haben die dann in dem neuen, in diesem unwichtigen Scheißbuch ja eigentlich, sind die dann in der Zeit gereist und haben alle Ereignisse verändert. Alle Ereignisse, weshalb wir dieses Franchise mögen. Toll, ja, kann ich mal in die Vordes wegschmeißen. Ja, ich kann alle meine Bücher zerfetzen. Toll. Aber das ist doch eine blöde Idee. Das macht ja das Universum wesentlich kleiner und die Geschehnisse auch wesentlich kleiner. Weil wer sagt uns, dass das, was wir gelesen haben, nicht die zehnte Abänderung ist von irgendwas, weil irgendjemand mit diesem Timeturner umgereist ist. Warum kann Voldemort nicht Zeit reisen? Es gibt nur drei, vier Zeit-Timeturner oder so, ja klar, aber das ist dann wiederum geschickt gelöst und das ist sehr illegal und die Auroren versuchen das genau zu verhindern. Bullshit. Na, hey, wir sind an einer Askerbahn, wir können nicht an so einem Franchise rumhaten. Das stimmt, das stimmt. Aber es ist, keine Ahnung, aber Ladenbesitzer, es gibt tausend Läden, der steht halt den ganzen Tag in seinem Laden und verkauft Bonbons und kann aber irgendwie tolle Zaubertränke brauen und kann irgendwie durch die Gegend fliegen und Quidditch spielen. Für mich ist das Berufsleben einfach nicht so erfüllend, wie ich mir denke, wenn ich in Hogwarts bin und ich mir, okay, ich bin Ladenbesitzer. Gut, hier, Gimli und Gloin, die Bruder von Ron. Gimli, Gloin, Oin, Boin, Scheun, Roin, Floin und Moin. Die können dann halt ihre Streichsachen verkaufen, wo du auch sagst, Moment mal, kann ich nicht auch einfach durch Zaubern irgendwie ein Furzkissen erscheinen lassen? Wie funktioniert fucking Akio, wie funktioniert Akio, kannst du dir einfach alles herbeizaubern, was du willst? Nein, ich glaube, du musst es schon mal, es muss in einem Raum, es muss in der Nähe sein. Nein, der ist ein Besen, der ist ganz weit weg. Es gibt so eine ganz, also auch in dem, der Accio ist so ein ganz, ganz pedantischer Zauberspruch, der irgendwann gesagt hat, so, ne, alles im Umkreis von zehn Metern ist okay, darüber hinaus nicht mehr. Ja, aber eine ganz klare Grenze muss es da geben. Du musst es irgendwie regeln, ansonsten ist es einfach... Aber du hast gerade, glaube ich, ein bisschen was durcheinander gemacht. Also die können ja nicht, also die beherrschen nicht alle Zauberer, beherrschen alle Zauber. Das ist, glaube ich, einfach mal, das muss man nur als Prämisse einfach akzeptieren. In dem Moment, wo du dich auf die Zauberstablehre konzentrierst, wie Ollivander, hast du einfach mehr drauf auf dem Gebiet. Du kannst einfach mehr. Deswegen hast du so einen Laden, weil du dich damit auskennst, weil du die reparieren kannst. Nicht jeder kann einen Zauberstab reparieren, weil es dafür keinen Zauberspruch gibt, sondern weil die alle, also durch diese ganze Zaubersache hat er alle Gegenstände, da haben er auch irgendwie ihre eigene... Du brauchst nur Lateinwörterbuchen, du kannst alles. Nein, die sagen ja auch am am Anfang, wie die Wingardium Livioso. Die Hälfte der Klasse sagt das falsch, weil sie einfach komplett Vollidioten sind. Wingardium Livioso. Ja, fick dich einfach. Wingardium Ceausescu. Nee, Robert, sag einfach, was ich in der Tafel geschrieben habe. Es ist auch nicht so, dass ihr in der ersten Klasse seid, ihr wart ja da schon irgendwie locker bestimmt zwölf Jahre alt oder sowas.
Wir können sprechen und lesen, das ist dumm, was ihr da macht. Auf der anderen Seite, die, die es richtig sagen, können ja auch nicht alle den Zauberspruch auslösen. Und das widerspricht doch gerade allem, was du gerade gesagt hast, weil du kannst Zaubersprüche ja auch Hermine ist die wesentlich bessere Zaubererin, Hexe als Harry Potter. Die kann einfach manche Sachen einfach besser. Vielleicht ist sie nicht so mächtig, weil ihr das nicht so in die Wiege gelegt wurde wie Harry Potter, aber sie ist einfach die bessere Hexe und kann einfach besser die Zaubersprüche sagen, deutlich ersprechen. Ja, das stimmt, aber Stotterer haben Riesenprobleme in der Welt. Was mich ohnehin fragt, hat man denn unendlich viel Zauberkraft? Also kann man unendlich viel zaubern? Das ist jetzt bei Rollenspiel, zum Beispiel bei DSA so, dass du halt so Mana hast und dann hast du nicht genug Mana. Dann kommst du immer in diese unangenehmen Situationen, dass du als Spieler weißt, ah, ich hab nur noch ganz wenig Mana, aber deine Figuren innerhalb der Welt sagen, oh mein Gott, schick einen Zauberball und du musst dann sowas sagen wie, meine astralen Kräfte lassen gerade, ich bin gerade nicht konzentriert.
Ich bin ziemlich groggy, der Tag war echt
anstrengend. Weil du willst ja nicht in deiner
Figur sagen, ich habe einfach keinen Mahler mehr.
Es ist ein bisschen wie beim Imperator.
Und so stelle ich mir das in der Harry Potter
Welt auch vor. Es ist ein bisschen so,
dass dir, wenn auch
so warm ist wie heute, ich glaube, dann hast
du irgendwann auch keine Kraft mehr. Das ist auch ein bisschen so
ein Körperenergie-Ding. Ich glaube, du kannst irgendwann auch nicht mehr, Ich glaube, Voldemort und Harry, die wären irgendwann auch zu groggy gewesen, als wir weitermachen. Die haben keine Lust mehr drauf. Welchen Harry-Potter-Zauberspruch würdest du gerne beherrschen in der echten Welt? Das ist eine gute Frage. Akio ist natürlich auf jeden Fall das Beste. Definitiv Akio. Akio Brezel. Akio W Akio-Witz. Wow, und wenn alle Jobs werden gelöst, du musst nichts mehr suchen, das ist auch gut. Fucking Akio einfach so. Angenommen, du sagst jetzt, Akio ist 50 Cent, wo kommen die her? Wird dir irgendeinem kleinen Bangladesch-Kind aus der hart verdienten Tasche gezogen und fliegen zu dir? Und wenn der dann sagt Akio, und dann steckt er dann zwischen euch in der Luft, weil eure Zauber sich ausgleichen. Das ist mega strange. Oder dann hast du ja der mächtigere Zauber, was auch immer das heißen soll. Total bescheuert. Naja, aber was kann man machen? Also was kann man machen? Sagen wir mal, wir gehen mal das Szenario durch. Der kleine Florentin kommt gerade aus Huffepuff. Also du hast gerade aus Huffepuff, hast du ein Abitur gemacht, Abschluss gemacht, deinen Zauberer-Examiner hast du bestanden. Wäre eigentlich gerne auf eine andere Schule gegangen, um ehrlich zu sein, aber leider kann man das ja nicht bestimmen. Ja, auf welche Schule warst du gerne gegangen? Ich wäre gerne nach Beautybox, äh, Beauty, nach Frankreich gegangen. Das sind nur Frauen, das sind Mädchengymnasium. Ich glaube. Es gibt auch einfach drei Gymnasium in der ganzen Welt. Ne, es gibt mehrere, habe ich mal nachgelesen, weil ich das so cool fand. Als Kind habe ich mich da so reingefuchst, dachte mir, wo würde ich denn eigentlich hinkommen, weil das ist ja in England und wo würde ich hinkommen? Und es gibt, glaube ich, irgendwo, ich glaube, die Deutschen würden irgendwo nach Skandinavien in so ein scheiß Internat kommen. Auch Kacke. Gibt es da auch eigentlich, weil es gibt es nur das Internatprinzip oder gibt es auch manchmal einfach Schulen? Also, dass man zu seinen Familien gehen kann und dann bist du einfach der mega weirde in der Nachbarschaft, weil du nicht auf die normale Schule gehst, sondern irgendeine Zauberschule. Hat bei Harry Potter auch nie mal der Staat gesagt, so, Leute, das Kind, was bei euch gewohnt hat, wo ist das die ganze Zeit, auf welcher Schule geht das eigentlich, dass da niemand mehr bist du durchgeworden. Naja, aber die sind ja alle unter diesem Muggelzauber. Ach Gott, ey! Es gibt ja auch bei diesem Trimagischen Turnier, dass alle Muggel, die da hingehen wollen, den fällt plötzlich was ein, dass sie da nicht hinwollen. Wir wollen zur Schwiegermutter fahren. Oh, haben wir nicht den Herd angelassen? Okay, jetzt ist der Herd aus. Na, Moment mal, sag mal, wollten wir nicht eigentlich noch Lotto spielen? Einfach so, den Rest ihres Lebens sind sie gefahren. Was ist mit unseren Nachbarn los, dass sie die ganze Zeit wegfahren? Trottel. Ja, genau. Aber jetzt hast du dann, es gibt ja auch dieses Triemagische Turnier, das fand ich mega cool, wie dann die ganzen anderen Schulen ankommen, weil die von Beaubontans, von Bounty, die kommen in dieser Kutsche an, die angeflogen kommen. So und dann. Nichts Besonderes mehr, wir haben schon fliegende Autos gesehen. Von Durmstrang, die kommen in dem Schiff, was auftaut aus dem Wasser. Nichts Besonderes, wir haben schon Fluttergräbel gesehen. Aber wie würde Hogwarts, wenn mal bei denen ein Trimagisches Turnier wäre, wie würde Hogwarts da ankommen? Vielleicht dieser Baum? Nee, ich dachte mit dem Zug, mit dem Hogwarts-Express. Da müssen ja Gletsgleise hinlegen. Ja, aber die bilden sich ja davor und verschwinden dahinter. Nö, das ist eine normale Zuglinie. Klar. Vor allem, wenn das so wäre. Welcher Trottler hat dann gesagt, ja, richtig, die beste Idee ist, wahrscheinlich eine normale Zuglinie zu bauen zu unserem Zauberschloss. Weißt du, wer den Hogwarts Express schon mal gesehen hat? Ich? Ich habe ihn auch schon mal gesehen. Ich habe den Hogwarts Express gesehen. Wo hast du den gesehen? In England. In Orlando habe ich ihn gesehen. Der echte? Nee, ich weiß nicht, ob das echte... Der fährt dann übers Wasser oder was nach Orlando. Nee, der fährt von Orlando, vom Island of Adventures, fährt der in den normalen Universal Park und dann fährt er wieder zurück. Ne, ich meine den echten Hogwarts Express in England. Aber wie... Der habe ich gesehen. Aber wie meinst du jetzt echt? Meinst du der echte, der auch gedreht wurde mit? Ja, den habe ich gesehen. Den habe ich noch nicht gesehen. Tja, mit ganz viel Dampf, der haut ganz viel Dampf raus. Gleis neunein Dreiviertel ist auch eine Megaidee. Ja, ist richtig gut. Gibt es neuneinhalb, warum dreiviertel? Weil es ist ja eigentlich genau dazwischen, naja. Schwer zu sagen, aber welchen Jobs würdest du annehmen? Würdest du irgendwie so einen Laden holen? Also ich glaube ja, du, ich glaube, du simplifizierst das gerade zu sehr mit dem Laden. Klar, Ladenbesitzer. Nein, Ollivander ist ja kein Ladenbesitzer, Ollivander ist einfach ein krasser Zauberstab, krasser Zauberstab-Singenie. Ja, aber auch bei so Gerichtsverhandlungen wird er dann zugeholt und liest dann die Zauberstäbe aus, wie so ein Pager oder so ein Handy, was damit gemacht wurde. Hat man eigentlich so eine Zulassung, um Zauberstab zu bekommen, wenn man eine Vorstrafe hat, kriegt man keinen Zauberstab oder sowas? Kann sein. Sein Personcheck? Ich meine ja sogar, dass man kann aus den Zauberstaben herauslesen, was für Flüche die zum Letzten begangen haben. Ah. Sowas kann, weiß ich nicht genau, sowas glaube ich kann der auch machen. Der ist einfach schon krass und der kann ja auch Zauberstäbe bestimmen dann. Da fragt ja Harry im letzten Teil, fragt dann, wen gehört das? Das ist der Zauberstraf von Bellatrix Lestrange. Und so weiter. Weil das der krumme Schwarze ist. Wow, danke, Set Design. Oscar, nope. Bisschen offensichtlich. Oder Job. Einfügen, je nachdem, was der Fall ist. Im Schnitt bitte beachten. Aber wenn ich mir natürlich so strange wäre und dann kriege ich so einen Zauberstab und dann ist es irgendwie so ein hell-pinker, irgendwie mit gelben Streifen. Ich denke mir, der Zauber sucht sich den Zauber aus. Ja, halt die Fresse einfach. Ich will den Schwarzen. Ich dachte mir immer. Kann ich den anmalen? Kriege ich den Edding? Kriege ich den Edding? Kann ich den einfach so einen Porthesslichen Zauberstab? Oliwender hat auch so eine Macht einfach. Erstmal hat er eine Monopolstellung. Für alle, die zuhören, Oliwender ist der, der die Zauberstäbe verkauft. Also, es ist so ein bisschen, erst mal hat er ein Monopol ein krasses, so auf dem Zauberstäben. Auch die Franzosen müssen zudem, auch die Russen müssen zudem. Auch fragwürdig. So, und dann hat er halt einfach die Macht, weil ich frag mich immer, warum haben alle Bösen diese Totenkopf-Zauberstäbe, wo dann irgendwie auch so böse Runen und einfach Tod und Hass draufstehen? Da macht auch im Umkehrschluss Ollivander die Böse. Eigentlich schon, ja. Und ich meine, Bellatrix Strange war auch mal ein kleines Mädchen, das auf Hogwarts vielleicht gegangen ist. Aber wem gibt der? Gibt der diesem kleinen Mädchen mit den gross Augen, die noch viel mit ihrer Hello Kitty Tasche, gibt der einfach so einen Zauberstab mit so einem toten Kopf drin und sagt, hey, schönes Leben, ich glaube, wir werden uns nie wiedersehen, weil du wirst bestimmt ganz toll irgendwie mal irgendwann Auro werden. Auf jeden Fall. In welches Haus du wohl kommst? Dann kommen die Kinder da an, der eine mit seinem fehlbestickten Zauberstab so, ja okay, Hufflepuff, und dann der mit seinem toten Kopf so zacken, wo man wie so ein Butterfly-Messer noch so ein Messer ausklappen kann am Zauberstab so, vielleicht Slytherin, viel Spaß. Vor allem, ich denke mir dann auch so, wenn man das mal auf die normale Welt transportiert, das Produkt sucht sich seinen Kunden aus, wenn ich in so ein Autohaus gehe, oh, jetzt hat der Porsche dich ausgesucht. Komisch. Das ist ganz schön scheiße. Das ist vor allem Ollivander, der, kein Wunder, warum der die Monopolstellung hat, aber warum der so reich ist, wahrscheinlich auch, weil er einfach entscheiden kann, was er gerade verkauft. Ich versuche das bei Restaurants zu machen. Ich mache so die Speisekarte auf und lasse es dann einfach auf mich wirken und lasse dann so, das Essen sucht sich mich aus und dann passt es auch. Aber man blättert einfach so durch. Wie scheiße das für die Eltern ist, wenn sich mal wieder der teuerste Zauberstab sein Kind aussucht. Wie kacke das ist. Willst du nicht den von Ja nehmen, vielleicht irgendwie, den in der weissen Packung? Ja, nicht mit dem hier. Da hinten ist einer von Medion, der sieht so ähnlich aus. Wenn du den nicht nehmen könntest. Und dann wirst du gemobbt in der Schule, weil du als einziger Medion-Mobile-Zauberstabler so sagst. Ja, der hat sich mich ausgesucht. Leute, komm schon, ey. Was sag ich denn dafür? Aber dem Mobbing wird entgegengewirkt, dadurch, dass die alle Roben tragen. Und diese Hausnummer ist auch echt so strange, ne, mit dem, weil, ich mein, die von Cithrin sind offensichtlich alle böse. Die haben einfach alle Bullies in ein Haus gesteckt und die wohnen in den Kerkern, irgendwo, in diesenerkerkruften. Auch irgendwie blöd, ne? Ich meine... Ne, ich glaube, es ist halt einfach so, es gibt ja das Konzept der Parallelklasse. Also du gehst in die Schule und es gibt die Parallelklasse. Und ich glaube, Rowling hat einfach so alle Formen von Parallelklassen in diese anderen Häuser genommen. Du bist Gryffindor, du bist die Kuhlen, klar, und dann gibt es halt noch die Vollidioten, die Streber und die Nerven, die Mobber.
So, dann gibt es die Rübel, Streber, Vollidioten und das sind Hufflepuff, Slytherin und Ravenclaw und genau so ist es halt so.
Und dann bist du ein Streber oder bist du ein Vollidiot oder bist du jemanden, der mobbt. Dann kommst du halt in diese Klassen rein.
Ravenclaw wohnt, glaube ich, in diesem Turm. Die wohnen in diesem Astrologieturm, oder zumindest in einem so einem großen Turm, in so einem schrägen, und die lesen alle und bilden sich. Und du kannst halt Lehrer werden. Warum ist Hermine nicht bei Ravenclaw? Weil die mutig ist, Mann! Mutig und Freundschaft! Aber vor allem ist sie schlau. Du kannst ja nicht einen Menschen auf einen einzigen Charakter zukredizieren. Ich glaube, wenn das einer kann, dann der sprechende Hut. Was ist das eigentlich für ein riesiges Arschloch einfach, dass so wirklich nach dümmsten Klischees geht? Und vor allem auch wie Harry dann sagt, nicht Slytherin, nicht Slytherin und du so und alle Slytherin so, äh, was soll das denn eigentlich? Das ist schlau. Kurz vorm Abschluss so, Alter, was ist das für ein Arschloch einfach?
Alle sagen so, okay Hufflepuff, okay Ravenclaw und so, bitte nicht Slytherin, kunkt an den Slytherin-Tisch.
Alter, wir hassen dich auch. Du bist gerade Eröffnungsfeier, so dein einziges Ziel sollte sein, verschärzt es dir mit möglichst wenigen.
Und er sagt quasi bei der Eröffnungsfeier, nicht in die A-Klasse, nicht in die A-Klasse.
Und die A-Klasse sitzt da und denkt sich, fuck you.
Und die denken sich so, wir wollen hier auch nicht sein, aber wir haben nun mal den Hakenkreuz-Zauberstab bekommen, was sollen wir denn machen? Es ist eine harte Welt. Und du wirst auch gemacht, wenn du Quidditch nicht gut bist, ist es Level Longbottom einfach massiv geworden. Gibt es auch einen Billard-Club? Nope, Quidditch. Ich bin ganz gut im Poker. Nope, Quidditch. Ja, toll. Zauberschach. Man kann viele Sachen machen, man kann auch professioneller Quidditchspieler werden. Ist Zauberschach eigentlich das exakt selbe wie Schach, nur man sagt Zauberschach, weil, kann ich bitte ein Glas Zaubermilch haben? Das ist ein bisschen wie, cut it, okay, beruhige dich, das ist normale Milch, ich weiß, es ist eine Zaubererwelt, aber es ist einfach nur normale Milch. Ja, das zieht die durch bis zum Bier, da ist es Butterbier. Und ab dann hat man vor alles Butter gesetzt. Das finde ich sehr gut. Das ist ein bisschen wie Star Wars, wo man vor alles Space setzen kann, so ein bisschen. So ein Space-Schwert mit seinem Space-Helm und seinem Space-Ship. Die ist blau. Es ist ein bisschen wie mit Zauber. Man hat da vor alles Zauber gesetzt. Es ist auch irgendwie, ja, ich verstehe schon. Aber Butterbier finde ich schon lustig. Vor allem Millionen Kinder in der ganzen Welt werden sich gefragt haben, Butterbier? Ja, und dann kam es ja irgendwann zu dem Problem, dass die Freizeitparks Butterbier anbieten wollten. Ich habe auch in Orlando ein Butterbier getrunken in Hockseed und lustigerweise stand da ja dann irgendwer vor der Frage, weil da steht ja kein Rezept drin.
Also Jake, just kidding, Rowling hat ja nicht einfach angefangen, Rezepte da reinzuschreiben, sondern die hat dann einfach gesagt, das ist Butterbier, also als Fakt, damit man diese Welt auch dann dementsprechend als Welt auffasst.
Und dann war halt irgendwer mal vor der Frage, ja und jetzt?
Dann haben die halt einfach, es hat so ein bisschen geschmeckt wie so eine Karamellsoda. Ja, dieses Cream Soda, ne, gibt's ja auch. Genau, ja. Das war es dann ungefähr. Ja, das war aber ganz lecker eigentlich. Ey, was für ganze fucking nervige Anrufe Jake Gyllenhaal-Rolling bekommen muss. Von wegen so, ey, sag mal, wie sehen denn eigentlich diese Karten aus? Ah, wie schmeckt denn eigentlich diese Süßigkeit, wir wollen hier diese Jellybeans machen, ich hab doch keine Ahnung, die hat jetzt, die hat jetzt die hat jetzt für 20 Jahren gesagt, so, in der Welt, in der ich schon immer lebe, lebt ihr jetzt seit 20 Jahren, so im Sinne von so, ah, ich hab euch in meine Welt gelassen, wo ich mir hatte, so, hm, wirklich, darin hast du die ganze Zeit schon gegeben, no. Ich bin, ich bewundere die. Weißt du, dafür, ich wäre so abgehoben. Wenn ich diese Person wäre, würde ich die ganze Zeit von meiner Welt sprechen und irgendwann auch einfach, ich würde auch so Arschlochmoves machen, wie Dinge behaupten, die alles zerstören. Zum Beispiel, dass Gandalf schwul ist, hat sie auch gesagt. Gandalf ist eins zu eins, Dumbledore, machen wir uns nichts vor. Da gibt es charakterlich null Unterschiede. Aber sie sagt, Gandalf ist schwul und sie so alle, hey, danke für Harry Potter, aber lass deine fucking Finger von der Ringe so, du kannst da nichts einnehmen machen. Aber auch, dass Dumbledore schwul ist, einfach so, einfach irgendwie hunderttausend homophobe Leute angepisst, so von wegen so, alter, was soll das? Aber sie so, nope, Hermine ist auch schwul und Snape ist auch schwul. Und wisst ihr was, dieser fucking dreiköpfige Hund, schwul, schwul, schwul, alle drei Köpfe, fickt euch. Und Hagrid steht auf Kinder. In den ersten Teilen hatten sie noch sehr viel miteinander zu tun, am Ende weniger, wo an Land was denn wohl? Hm, Gerichtsprozess. Ja, aber genauso wäre ich doch auch. Und ich muss sagen, Respekt an dich, JK, ohne ohne Scheiße, ey. Der hat das Game dann doch eigentlich bis zum Ende ganz souverän und nicht durchgespielt. Ey, Jotka Fischer hat das von Anfang bis Ende richtig gut gemacht, finde ich. Ich finde es einfach gut gehandelt. Aber sollte sie jetzt loskommen von dem Franchise oder sagt mir, immer da bleiben. Nein, mehr Bücher, mehr Bücher. Ich würde auch jedes noch lesen. Doch mir macht es einfach Spaß, weil es so ist, dass es gut ist. Hier nicht Harry-Buch auch nicht gelesen, sondern so, ich mache jetzt was anderes als Harry Potter. Ist wieder Dobby dabei? Nein, Dobby ist nicht dabei. Stimmt, wir haben Krimi geschrieben. Ja, interessiert keinen. Stimmt, der soll auch echt schlecht gewesen sein. Du kannst dann auch nichts anderes mehr machen. Also ich meine, nie wieder. Lustigerweise heißt sie gar nicht, dieses K, wofür auch immer das das Joanne K. Rowling, sie heißt keinen zweiten Namen mit K. Aber es gab schon Joan Rowling, eine bekannte Neonazi-Anführerin und so. Ah, ich bin Joan K. Es war so, dass die Verlagsleute nicht wollten, dass eine Frau geschrieben hat, dass Leute wissen, dass es eine Frau geschrieben hat, weil die dachten, wenn eine Frau das geschrieben hat, verkauft sich das nicht.
Niemand liest eine Geschichte von einer Frau. Und das ist schon krass, weil das ja auch noch gar nicht so lange her ist. Naja, es gibt ja mega viele weibliche Autoren, oder? Ja, zum Beispiel Nele Neuhaus. Gott sei Dank ist mir einer eingefallen. Jojo Moyjes. Ähm. Ähm. George. Aber das heißt, müssen eigentlich alle so Musikern, um die Stille zu übertönen. Nein. Haben wir jetzt eine Musikermann von eigentlich drin? Weil das geht mal. Nee, nee, haben wir gehört. Nee, aber es ist interessant, das heißt, dass dann eigentlich alle aber es kann ja sein, dass es bei ganz vielen
Autoren das eigentlich Frauen sind.
Weil wenn die den Erfolg haben...
Was nervt dich am meisten an dem
Franchise? Bei mir ist es eine Charakterkonstellation,
mit der ich nicht klarkomme
und es nervt mich
auch bis, wird mich in all die Ewigkeit
nerven, es ist
diese Ginny-Harry-Nummer.
Weil ich finde Ginny den nervigsten Charakter. Ich kann mich auch nicht mal an die Bücher erinnern, vielleicht war sie da cooler, aber ist sie in den Filmen so nervig, so eine hilfsbedürftige Person, die einfach nichts kann, die nichts leistet, die gerettet wird am Anfang und irgendwann mit ihm zusammenkommt. Das bahnt sie auch nicht mal richtig an. So wenn er mit dieser Joe zusammengekommen wäre am Ende. Oder mit Luna Lovegood. Das wäre einfach eine Person, die man lieben gelernt hat, für die man gehofft hat. Aber die Freundin, die Schwester seines besten Freundes, Harry! Das ist auch ein fucking dick Move. Harry! Ja! Was soll das denn, ey? Aber es muss halt alles so geklingelt werden. Es müssen dann alle Figuren sein, die man schon kennt. Ja, aber man kennt ja doch genug Frauen, mit denen er was hätte anfangen können. Ich fände es gut, wenn der mit einer Mogelfrau zusammengekommen wäre. Die Brown, die lustigerweise in den ersten Teilen eine schwarze war. Und dann mussten sie sie casten. Oh nein, sie hat eine Sprechrolle. Whoops und weiss. Wirklich, exakt so lief das. Richtig gut, richtig lustig. Und gut. Finde ich richtig gut. Aber wurde nicht auch Malfoy's Posse plötzlich schwarz, dieser Crab und Goyle? Der Typ, der einfach Crab genannt wurde von seinen liebevollen Eltern, einfach so. Seid ihr wirklich meine Freunde? Ihr nennt mich immer Crab. Kann ich nicht zumindest Crab heißen wie Mr. Crabs? Nein, du heisst Crab. Und ich muss sagen, also das nervt mich wirklich, weil Ginny ist einfach eine nervige Randfigur, die man nicht lieben lernt, finde ich so richtig. Ich finde ohnehin alle Filme ab drei sind scheiße. Drei ist noch gut, aber drei ist der beste Film. Drei ist perfekt, drei ist recht, du hast viele coole Elemente, du hast einen coolen Anfang mit diesem Wolf, es wird düster, du hast diesen coolen Bus, Harry ist mal auf sich alleine gestellt, der ist nicht immer
so umringend von seinen ganzen Freunden,
sondern macht mal alleine was, das
Zeitding ist cool, aber danach ist halt alles kaputt.
Oder auch dieser ganze,
dass es diesen Trank gibt, wo man sich in andere
Leute verwandeln kann, wird auch nie wieder
verwendet, aber es ist das Beste, was es geben kann.
Doch, das wird immer verwendet, in jedem fucking Film wird das verwendet.
Wirklich? Ja, wird auch wieder verwendet. Ach ja, stimmt, du hast ja
dann, du musst dich alle in Harry verwandeln.
Ja, Matt i Moody ist dann noch dieser krasse Typ,
der Hochstapler, der ja gar nicht
... Immer verwendet, in jedem fucking Film wird das verwendet. Wirklich? Ja, wird auch wieder verwendet. Ach ja, stimmt, du hast ja dann, du musst dich alle in Harry verwandeln. Ja, Mad-Eye Moody ist dann noch dieser krasse Typ, der ja ein Hochstapler, der ja gar nicht Mad-Eye Moody war, sondern da war ja nur der Sohn von dem. Ja, du hast völlig recht, das wird sehr, sehr oft verwendet. Das stimmt, also Drei ist der beste Film, der ist von Alfonso Cuaron directed worden, ein richtig guter, bis dahin hat er nur Indie-Filme gemacht und so, und dann macht er plötzlich das große Franchise. Durchbruch. Mega-Film und danach halt sowas wie Gravity. Naja, auch die Busfahrerszene am Anfang sieht einfach richtig gut aus. Ja, und auch die Dementoren. Dementoren sind eine gute Idee. Dementoren! Halt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Hogwarts, gefährlich, Hogwarts und auch eine ganz wahnsinnig aktuelle Debatte, wie weit, wie muss man seine eigene Sicherheit einschränken, um dann auch, muss man die eigene Freiheit einschränken, um Sicherheit zu gewährleisten. Holt man sich so Dementoren nach Hogwarts, die räumen halt mal auf, aber dafür kann es halt nachts nicht nach Hause gehen. Das sind exakt diese Terrordebatte, die jetzt geführt wird. Und das vor ein paar Jahren, wo von Terror noch nie die Rede war. Absolut. Also ich fand, das war wirklich toll, irgendwie da auch ganz fein. Der elf Jahre alte Florentin sass im kino dachte mir gefällt diese sicherheitsdebatte total freiheit aber zu welchem preis sympathisch der menschen in der letzten reihe die ganze zeit von freiheit spricht wie viele film hast wie viele film hast du im kino gesehen freiheit aber zu behalten die halt deine fresse sicherheit ja aber wie wie viel Freiheit sind wir dafür bereit einzubüssen?
Und übrigens, in Minute acht war ein Filmstrich.
Achtet mal auf den Mantel, gleich hat er ihn nicht mehr an.
Alter, Filmfehler.
Ihr trefft mich, ihr trefft mich mit dem Filmfehlerforum.
Ich heiss Tyrion Lannister mit einem N, aber drei R. Ach Gott, shut up. Schrecklich. Wie viele Harry Potter Filme hast du im Kino gesehen? Wow, bestimmt fünf, sechs. Ich glaube, die ersten paar danach nicht mehr. Aber wir haben einen großen Marathon gemacht, wo wir, als der letzte Film rauskam, haben wir alle der vorgehenden Harry PotterFilme am Stück angeschaut und sind dann ins Kino gefahren, und ich war sehr müde, und haben dann die letzten Filme gesehen. Aber die letzten Filme waren irgendwie auch so dieses... Die letzten haben mir wieder gefallen. Mir gefällt der erste von den beiden letzten Teilen, hat mir gefallen. Es gibt dann aber auch so Sachen, dass die sich dann multiplizieren und dann wie so Zellteilungen, wo man auch für den Kino denkt, ja gut, okay, Welthunger, einfach Weltwirtschaft gelöst, einfach, es gibt unendlich viele Gegenstände.
Das sind krasse Zaubersprüche und die kosten viel Macht und für welchen Preis werden die, dieser Vielsafttrank, das ist ja auch das spannende Beispiel und auch der widerspricht deiner ganzen dummen Logik, die ganze Versuchst du an den Mann zu bringen, nämlich der Vielsafttrank ist ein unfassbar mächtiger Trank, du kannst jemandem anderen werden, aber der Preis, um den zu machen, ist unfassbar hoch, du musst unfassbar viel Zeit aufwenden, es dauert Monate, den zu machen, unfassbar teuer und die Materialien, die du verbrauchst, kriegst du eigentlich auch normalerweise. Ja, kriegt aber eine elfjährige Schülerin. Erstlässler haben das dann hingekriegt, aber es ist halt trotzdem schon aufwendig und ich glaube, wenn du halt diesen Zauber machst, wo das Geld sich multipliziert in der Zelle, glaube ich, von Bellatrix to Change, dann ist das einfach ein krasser Zauber gewesen. Und dementsprechend kann das auch nicht jeder, sondern dann musst du halt schon so ein Geldmultiplikator-Professor sein, um das hinzubekommen. In Teil drei sind ja auch einmal in so einer Taverne, und da sieht man, dass es einen so einen Wischmob gibt, der alleine putzt. Wo ich mir denke, okay, eine gesamte Berufsgruppe ausradiert. Es gibt im Grunde eigentlich keinen Dienstleistungssektor mehr in der Zauberwelt. Doch, die Leute, die das programmieren. Das sind ja wie Staubsaugerroboter. Exakt das Gleiche. Das stimmt. Das sind die modernen Staubsaugerroboter. Das ist auch Zeitgeistkritik, also es ist ganz hauchfein. Wirklich? Aber mir gefällt, wie du die ganze Zeit von Skeptisch in Richtung Bewunderung gehst. Wow, du, alles ist schon drauf, es ist schon alles gar nicht so schlecht.
Aber es fällt auf, dass die Filme alle so ein Thema haben, eigentlich so.
Der erste ist so, gut, neue Welt.
Fuck it, wir wissen nicht, was daraus wird.
Zweite ist, du wirst mit deiner Vergangenheit und deinen Problemen konfrontiert als Harry.
Dritter ist, wow, langsam wird's bitter ernst.
Vierte, weiß ich nicht mehr. Irgendwann hast du, der fünfte, ist glaube ich der, wo die Hormone komplett durchdrehen, Ron mit dieser Brown zusammenkommt und so eine nervige Comic-Relief-Story damit laufen hat, aber das ist schon, jeder hat schon so, und Harry wird auch in einem richtig gemobbt. Also in einem ist gar nicht mehr jeder auf seiner Seite, und er war ja immer der Hochgelobte und der mit den Vorschusslorbeeren. In einem Teil wird er richtig gemobbt auch. Ich habe schon ein bisschen Bock, jetzt einen Film anzuschauen, Herr Potter Film. Ja, hätte ich auch Bock drauf. Ich glaube, den dritten habe ich oft gesehen. Oder auch hier, du sagst, es gibt ja auch Heilzauber. Und es gibt ja nicht... Noch einen Trank. Genau, ohne Grund gibt es ja Madame Pomfrey. Ist das die aus dem Krankenflügel? Und die heilt da alle und macht es auch gut. Die macht einen guten Job, einen richtig guten Job zu einem fairen Preis. Ich habe jetzt auch überhaupt nichts gegen Madame Pomfrey gesagt. Ich finde, doch, die ganze Zeit unterschwellig kommen so Stiche gegen Madame Pomfrey. Und ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, sie verdient bestimmt nicht genug dafür, dass sie so einen tollen Job... Ey, da sollte man echt mal was sagen, ja. Ich meine, dafür, dass sie in so einem... Das ist ein Dienstleistungssektor, die hat einen tollen Job und dann kommt dieser Typ da aus Gilderoy Lockhart, der die dann, der Harry seinen Arm reparieren will und dann verschwinden die Knochen. Das kann nämlich passieren, wenn eine Laie das macht. Auch da eine tolle Kritik überlassen sie den Profis. Hätte er es mal lieber an Mrs. Pomfrey gehalten. Madame Pomfrey gehalten, weil die hat es nämlich drauf. Die hat ihn ja auch dann ganz schnell wieder fit bekommen mit dem Kürbistrank. Das muss man schon sagen. Ich glaube, Kürbisse ist ein grosser Dienstleistungssektor. Was für uns so Öl ist, ist für die Zauberwelt Kürbisse einfach. Weil du brauchst Kürbisse. Kürbisknappheit! Alle Raunen überall. Die kommen auch nie wieder vor, diese schreienden Dinge. Und Einhornblut im ersten Teil, im zweiten Teil? Irgendwann trinkt doch Voldemort Einhornblut, weil er ewig jung bleiben will. Warum ist das nicht ein grösseres Thing danach? Gute Frage. Wenn man davon weiß, warum geht dann nicht jeder in diesen scheiß Wald? Gut, es ist der verbotene Wald. Gut. Aber das ist auch so ein bisschen ... Wenn man da reingeht, muss man zur Strafe in den Wald reingehen. Wow, das ist eine gute Idee. Genau, aber dann warum versucht nicht jeder einfach, das Leben ist doch scheißegal, du brauchst auch keinen Job, wenn du ewig lebst, brauchst du ja nichts mehr. Wofür lebst du dann noch? Dann kannst du ja einfach dein eigenes Business am Laufen haben. Ja, gut, aber wie stark forschst du jeden Tag nach dem ewigen Leben, Stefan Tietze? Du, indem ich mich hier bei guter Arbeit in Sketchen verwirkliche. Das ist eine gute Antwort, das ist eine gute Antwort, abonnieren. Ja, und dann sind wir im Wald. Und man muss auch sagen, die verbotene Abteilung, der verbotene Wald, diese Leute, die den Namen gegeben haben, sind nicht die besten Leute, auch nicht die besten Pädagogen. Die verbotene Herdplatte, jeder hatte sie zu Hause. Auf jeden Fall. Und alle haben draufgefasst. Klar. Ja, und alle waren im Wald und in der verbotenen Abteilung schon Teil 1. Die verbotene Schublade. Es funktioniert einfach nicht. Nenn ihn einfach Kaubelwald. Das ist der Kaubelwald. Und niemand würde sagen, boah, da müssen wir unbedingt rein. Oder Schwarzwald oder so. Einfach so ein boring Wald. Aber Schwarz klingt schon bedrohlich. Schwarzwald. Ich denke mir da immer so, was lauert da? Was lauert da im Schwarzwald? Im Harz. Was ist da los? Im Harz. So, ich habe hier die Seite offen, was ist noch? Also, man kann eine Ausbildung machen, Medimag, was sind Medimagier? Medimagier sind eine Art magischer Sanitäter, das hatten wir eben schon mal. Muggel, Verbindungspersonen, es gibt ja die Muggelregierung. Ja, das ist auch aber Ministerium, ist auch Zauberministerium. Genau, aber die wissen ja, lustigerweise wissen die Muggel ja, die Muggel-Regierung, weil es ist ein bisschen Area 51-mässig, die Regierung weiss nämlich von den Zauberern. Echt? Ja, und die tolerieren das und akzeptieren das. Warum fragen die nicht um Hilfe, wenn jetzt irgendwie hier Saddam Hussein? Ja, das ist eine gute Frage. Ich glaube, die wollen nicht, dass die Bevölkerung davon weiss. Warum nicht? Wir ja nicht um Hilfe, weil sich dann alle schlecht fühlen, weil die meisten Leute einfach unskilled sind. Ich lese mal nach, vor was die Verbindungsperson macht. Das Zaubereiministerium hat in fast allen Abteilungen Arbeitsbereiche eingerichtet, deren Aufgabe es ist, gute Beziehungen zu Muggeln zu wahren. Obwohl von allen diesen Abteilungen ab und zu Fachleute für Muggelbelange gefragt sind, hat der Beruf nur ein geringes Ansehen.
Wie dürftig die Arbeitsbedingungen und die Bezahlung professioneller Muggelfreunde sind, zeigt das Beispiel von Arthur Weasley.
Dementsprechend wird auch nicht viel für diesen Beruf verlangt. Ein ZAG in Muggelkunde genügt.
Heißt, es gibt durchaus auch Ausbildungen, also man muss die ZAG machen. Muggelkunde. Zusätzlich gefragt sind Enthusiasmus, Geduld und Humor. Das ist eine lange, ziemlich boring Stellenausschreibung. Gefragtes Humor ist eigentlich nicht schlecht. Und Excel. Kenntnis in Excel. Harry meint, dass Humor nicht ausreichend wird, um mit Muggeln wie seinem Onkel Vernon klarzukommen. Der Harry hat schon manchmal ein paar Sprüche drauf. Aber das muss eigentlich der beste Job sein, weil du die ganzen Tage mit Leuten zu tun hast, die dir massiv unterlegen sind. Die mal sagen, Öl, Öl, Snickers, Snickers und du halt so hier Accio, Ding, zack, haben wir gelöst, Zaubertrank. Das ist gruselig. Es gibt sogenannte Vergissmichs, Oblivators. Als Angestellte des Zaubereiministeriums, Abteilung für magische Unfälle und Katastrophen,
löschen sie die Erinnerungen von jedem Muggel, der etwas Magieverdächtiges erlebt oder gesehen hat.
Das heißt, die reisen immer hinter diesen Schlachten hinterher und halten den Muggel die Zauberstäbe ins Gesicht und lassen sie vergessen.
Die blitztienst.
Das ist nicht schlecht. Das ist ein geiler Job. Das würde ich machen, glaube ich. Aber die müssen nur einen Zauberspruch können.
Ja. Das ist ein geiler Job. Das ist ein cooler Job, aber die müssen nur einen Zauberspruch können. Das ist auch schon strange, ey. Aber du hast da bestimmt mega die Paranoia, oder? Weil ich würde dann auch immer die Gedächtnisse von den Leuten löschen, dass die das auch nicht weitersagen können. Weil die kennen ja alle die ganzen Geheimnisse. Die kennen ja die ganzen Staatsaffären, die ganzen Sachen. Ja, vor allem kommst du als Oblivator dann zu deinem Vorgesetzten bis zum Mitarbeitergespräch, weil du einen Fehler gemacht hast. Und dann können wir die Sache nicht beide vergessen und holst dann so einen Zauberstafel vor. Ja, stimmt schon. Du willst auch nicht der Abteilungsleiter von dem Vergiss mal nicht sein. Nee. Einfach so, ich bin heute zu spät, ich habe vergessen, dass ich heute einen Termin habe. Wirklich? Ernsthaft? Also wirklich? Ich habe das schon vergessen. Ich habe das einfach vergessen. Sind Sie heute zu spät gekommen? Nope. Ah ja. Was machen Sie in meinem Büro? Man hat viele Fragen. In welchem Büro bin ich hier? Warum arbeite ich Ah, okay, wir lassen es. Abteilung implodiert einfach. Die können sich selbst auf. Ja, die können viele Katastrophen ausrichten. Ja, die können auch einfach zu Voldemort gehen und sagen, ding, oh, ich wollte gar nicht die Welt umstürzen. Da traust du dich aber was, dass du deinen Namen nennst. Ich habe keine Angst vor Voldemort, Alter, der kann mich mal. Ich sag mal so, Volde-Arschloch. Okay, nix. Ich frag mich immer, wie Voldemort es geschafft hat, so viele Herrscharen um sich zu sammeln. Wegen coolen Zeichen in der Luft. Ja, es ist, glaube ich, sowas, weil der bietet ja nicht so richtig viel. Also die Welt ist ein bisschen so wie Scar bei König der Löwen. Man weiss, wenn man sich ihm anschließt und gewinnt, dann wird es alles so so ein Brachland, überall verbrannte Erde, traurige Welt. Ich glaube, es ist generell sehr leicht, Anhänger zu finden. Egal, welchen Zweck du verfolgst, Anhänger finden sich immer. Menschen haben ein Bedeutungsvakuum in sich, das sie nur zu gerne füllen würden mit jedem dahergelaufenen Trottel, der kommt.
Hey, übrigens, ich habe Bock, Hornissen komplett zu bekämpfen auf der ganzen Welt. Hast du Bock, dich anzuschießen? Klar, Alter, Hornissen machen wir fertig. Ich glaube, es ist es nicht. Den Rest des Lebens kämpfst du gegen Hornissen. Sobald du Leuten Bedeutung anbietest, wird es genug Leute geben, die sich da dranhängen, die sagen, jetzt hat mein Leben einen Sinn. Ich glaube, es ist eher sowas wie Stolz.
Leute sind gern stolz auf etwas.
Und es fällt ja auch, dass Leute, die sowas wie Nazis oder so, jetzt hat mein Leben einen Sinn. Ich glaube, es ist eher so etwas wie Stolz. Leute sind gern stolz auf etwas
und es fällt ja auch, dass Leute,
die so etwas wie Nazis oder so,
dass die oft
wenig gebildet sind. Stolz auf ihr Land sind.
Genau, sie sind stolz auf ihr Land und das ist tatsächlich
einfach, die haben oft wenig, sorry,
wenig geleistet, die haben
wenig Karriere gemacht.
Selbstbewusstsein, ja. Genau, wenig Selbstbewusstsein
und der geringste gemeinsame Nenner, den sie mit anderen haben, ist das Land. Das einzige, worauf sie stolz sein können, ist das Land. Sie können auf nichts anderes stolz sein. Und deswegen glaube ich, ist einfach der einzige gemeinsame Nenner zwischen diesen ganzen Leuten, ist das Land und Nationalpatriotismus. Das ist es, glaube ich, schon. Und ich glaube, dann kannst du es schaffen, Leute um dich zu versammeln. Wenn du dir dann noch Strukturen gibst, und das können sie sich hocharbeiten, und dann kriegst du noch so Regeln, und die einfach zu verstehen sind, wen du mögen musst und wen du nicht mögen musst, was du sagen darfst, was du nicht sagen darfst, und gibt es dir noch so ein System, wo die sich gegenseitig noch anfeuern können, hochstacheln können,
dann glaube ich, hast du alles erreicht.
Ja, was bietet Voldemort? Der bietet halt Macht und Einfluss und sagen,
okay, ich werde eh die Welt in Schutt und Asche legen, sei lieber auf der Gewinnerseite.
Und am Ende kriegst du von mir einen schicken, schicken Lambo.
Lambo.
Und warum haben diese Fragen über Fragen?
Aki und Lambo.
Dieses fliegende Auto, das war ja auch dem Weasley sehr wichtig, ne? Ja. Warum holt er sich nicht aus seiner Muggelwelt einen Lambo? Ja genau. Und warum hat er nicht einfach ein besseres Auto? Warum hat er nicht eine Rakete oder ein Flugzeug oder so? Weil, Rakete? Rakete? Ja, das ist eine gute Frage. Kannst du auch besser fliegen? Ah, Mr. Weasley. Die wohnen in diesem geilen Haus, dem Fuchsbau. In diesem abgefahrenen Zauberhaus. Auch das verstehe ich nicht ganz, weil die haben sich ja so zurückgezogen an so einen einsamen Ort und haben Platz, um einen Platz zu haben und sich ausbreiten zu können und so. Das ist eine große Familie. Dann gibt es aber irgendwann dieses Zelt, was Hermine hat.
Oder auch die Weasleys haben, wo man reingehen kann.
Ist ganz klein von außen, dann geht man rein und es ist ein riesiges Zelt.
Warum haben die das, warum wohnen die nicht auch in sowas?
Wird man da eigentlich klein, wenn man da eintritt?
Ja, das ist die Frage. Wird man klein, aber das Zelt einfach nur, nee.
Ich glaube, eigentlich, man wird klein, oder? Dieser Zauber, weil Hermin hat auch diese Tasche, wo alles reinpasst und es ist leicht. Diese Tasche ist eigentlich der wertvollste Gegenstand aller Zeiten, weil dieser Zauber ist Wahnsinn. Du kannst ja ganze Universen da drin haben. Was passiert denn, wenn du so dieses Zelt ins Wasser wirfst oder so und dann so das wie so ein Eimer voller Wasser laufen lässt und da passt unendlich viel rein? Dann saugt es einfach das gesamte Meer ein oder was? Das gesamte Wasser der Erde in Hermines Tasche? Hier habt ihr die Heringe zum Aufstellen und ich sag's dir noch einmal, lass das nicht in den Ozean fallen. Es ist ein Riesenproblem. Auch gar keinen Fall. Und dann irgendwie die ganze Welt geht kaputt, irgendwie stelle mir die gesamte Welt ohne Wasser vor für einen Tag, alles kaputt, alles im Arsch. Sämtliche Fische sind tot, alles ausgetrocknet, gesamte Ökosystem hinüber. Und dann alle so, Hermine! Und sie so, okay. Sorry! Und gießt wieder alles ins Meer. Das ist ein Riesenproblem. Wie viele von diesen Taschen gibt es? Auch nur drei auf der ganzen Welt. Es gibt auch nur drei Snickers in der gesamten Zaubererwelt. Ja, ist gut, Kinder. Ja, weil die so mächtig sind. Ich habe eins der Zaubertwicks, es gibt nur drei. Ja. Es gibt von allem nur drei. Es ist einfach, das ist wie so ein bisschen DDR-mässig. Es gibt einfach nur von jedem eine bestimmte Stückzahl. Mensch, wir kritisieren aber hier links und rechts umrundet. Du hast die Nationalsitzende, das wird die Neonazi-Szene irgendwie komplett auserkann genommen. Und du hast das Twicks zerstört, ey. Und die DDR angegriffen. Heikele Folge von der Antenne Aska. Du weißt ja was, ich lehne mich aus dem Fenster. Ich habe heute mal was gegen Nass gesagt, okay, wenn das manchen nicht passt, ich nehme mal kein Blatt vor den Mund. Stefan nimmt wirklich überhaupt nichts vor den Mund. So gut wie nichts. Was nimmst du vor den Mund? Gabel. Okay. Touché. Den Harry schon die ganze Zeit hat. Hätte man vielleicht auch schon mal ein bisschen was erfahren können. Erstmal, warum reagieren
alle so mega casual auf,
dass er das Heiligtum des Todes hat?
Die mächtigsten Dinge.
Und er kriegt sonst zu Weihnachten
diesen Umhang. Alle so, okay,
das ist ein Umhang. Die wissen ja davon.
Auch hier McGonagall.
Die McGonagall.
Ich weiss ja auch davon.
Die sind alle so mega cool. Und die hat noch nie davon gehört,
dass es dieses Heiligtum des Todes ist. Ja, keine Ahnung.
Das hat er jedenfalls von Anfang an. Stell dir mal vor, du verlierst
Sie die Gunna Girl Gunna Girl, ich weiss ja auch davon die sind alle so mega cool und die hat noch nie davon gehört, dass es dieses Heiligtum des Todes ist ja keine Ahnung, das hat er jedenfalls von Anfang an stell dir mal vor, du verlierst den Umhang erstes Mal, das ist die fucking du verlierst dein Kind im Supermarkt, was diesen Umhang gerade trägt, du findest es aber im Einges, oh nein Harry Potter schnell, bring den Umhang des Todes wir haben jetzt alle drei Teile ganz kurz, kurz, wenn jeder im Umkreis von sich selber mal kurz guckt,
bitte, kurz guckt, du findest
den unsichtbaren Umhang doch nie wieder.
Ich hätte einen Moment in meiner
Unterrichtszeit, wo ich gern
Harry Potter gewesen wäre, und es war dann die Frage,
wer kennt noch irgendwelche Maler,
und ich habe den Rotwein
Melo vorgeschlagen als
Maler, und da hätte ich gern, wäre ich gern
Harry Potter, der dann aus dem Unterricht plötzlich einfach
verschwindet, weil ich den Umhang aufsetzt und ich die Tür
Ich bin der Und ich habe den Rotwein Melo vorgeschlagen als Maler. Und da hätte ich gern, wäre ich gern Harry Potter, der dann aus dem Unterricht plötzlich einfach verschwindet, weil ich den Umhang aufsetze und die Tür rausgehe. Harry, wir wissen, dass du immer noch da bist. Warum hat er den Umhang nie beim Quidditch getragen? Einfach den Quidditch-Anzug und du bist der unsichtbare Blitz. Klanate-Regeln. Ja? Klanate-Regeln. Ist das wirklich in den Regeln, dass du... Der unsichtbare Blitz war ja wohl mega geil gerade. Ja. Jeden Blitz, weil er den Blitzer verstehen hat. Total, aber das war doch erst die Absicht. Klar, da Roletti war das. Aber es steht wirklich im Regelwerk zu Quidditch, dass man nicht das Unheiligtum des Todes den Unsichtbarkeit von einem tragen kann. Das, was man nicht darf, ist wesentlich grösser als das, was man darf. Die Regeln sind in der Nichtform geschrieben. Das wird doch auch ständig passieren, irgendwie so wie Snape, der dann mit seinem Zauberstab in das Quidditch-Spiel eingreift. Das wird doch ständig passieren. Aber worauf ich hinaus wollte, diese Heilige Tüme des Todes. Ich habe bis ab Ende nicht verstanden, was dieser Stein der Auferstehung kann. Ich dachte, dass er am Ende, musste er ja sterben, weil er der letzte Horcrux ist, weil ein Teil von Voldemort, das war quasi der erste Horcrux, der entstanden ist, weil ein Teil von Voldemort in Harry übergegangen ist. Okay, dann dachte ich mir, okay, die überlisten das, indem Harry den Stein der Auferstehung besitzt. Weil wenn er den besitzt, dann kann er sich umbringen lassen, hat aber den Stein der Auferstehung und lebt dann. Und der Fluch ist besiegt und er kann Voldemort töten. Tatsächlich habe ich aber herausgefunden, dass das ja gar nicht so funktioniert, sondern der Stein der Auferstehung nur diese ganzen Leute um ihn herum nochmal zeigt.
Sirius Black ist dann plötzlich da,
seine Mutter ist da, James Potter ist da. Nur zeigt, nicht mal aufweckt, sondern nur zeigt.
Halb, die sind halt dann da und wünschen
ihm alle gute Reise.
Die sind halt nochmal da und sagen,
er braucht keine Angst vor dem Tod zu haben. Das sagen sie.
Und dann verschwinden sie.
Und das war der Stein der Auferstehung.
Aber Harry lebt doch am Ende. Wie hat er denn überlebt?
Er hat überlebt?
Ich weiss nicht, ob wir die sechzehnte Folge Antenne Asker waren
wirklich so bestreiten sollen.
Stefan Denkrat wirklich extrem konzentriert nach. Ehrlich gesagt, bei solchen Plot-Sachen schalte ich immer aus. Mir ist alles scheißegal, was die Plot-Sachen. Ich will sehen, ich will das Quidditch-Spiel sehen, ich will die Drachen sehen, ich will den Hogwarts-Mart hören, aber diese Plot-Sachen, dieses Hogwarts-Sachen, ist mir alles egal. Ich hätte auch lieber eigentlich so eine Sitcom mal in der Welt. Ja. Oder so eine normale Soap-Opera
in der Welt, weil mich interessiert
die Welt viel mehr als die Geschichten, die darin
passieren. Total.
Ich will kurz ein Nachlesen.
Hätten die ganzen Hogwarts-Schule nicht einfach auf eine andere
Uni gehen können, als da irgendwie alles abgebrannt ist
und irgendwie alles kaputt gegangen ist?
Ja, dann gehen wir jetzt auf diese russische Uni.
Ciao.
Ah, der Elternstab hat nämlich gehorcht. und irgendwie alles kaputt gegangen ist, ja dann gehen, der ihn entwaffnet hat. Ne, weil der Sirus, weil der Snape, jedenfalls hat der Elternstab ihm nicht, ähm, und nächste Woche, wir haben den Asker waren.
Wir lernen die Basics. Aber tatsächlich nehme ich davon nichts mit, mich interessiert.
Ich weiß mich auch nicht so sehr. Ich finde auch, darum geht es auch gar nicht mehr, weil ich die Geschichte über den Verlust seiner Eltern und das ganze Klarkommen damit, Freunde finden, erwachsen werden, diese Coming-of-Age-Nummer, Freunde finden, Vaterfigur finden, das ist doch alles viel cooler, als dann, wie dann am Ende der Kampf mit dem Erzfeind, dieses überkonstruierte Bullshit-Ding, wie das ausgeht. Das ist doch egal. Ich könnte dir echt, glaube ich, von 80 Prozent aller Filme, die ich gesehen habe, nicht den Plot sagen. Ich auch nicht. Avengers. Habe ich nie gesehen. Irgendwelche Monster greifen an, die irgendeinen Stein wollen, irgendeine Ahnung. Gunness of the Galaxy, warum da jetzt am Ende genau das so, keine Ahnung, überhaupt keine Ahnung. Ich kann mich an diesen Baumann erinnern und dass ich irgendwie zwei Tüten Popcorn gegessen habe, noch vor der ersten Hälfte des Films. Daran kann ich mich erinnern, einen Rest nicht, der Rest ist mir auch egal. Ja, das stimmt. Das stimmt. Mich interessiert auch meistens die Welten mehr als die Stories da drin. Wenn die Welten halt in solchen Filmen halt, weißt du, in solchen Franchise-Filmen, wo die Welt wichtiger ist als die Story. Wenn du jetzt in Eternal Sunshine of the Spotters Mind guckst, dann kannst du die Story wahrscheinlich wiederholen. Nämlich? Ja, der träumt immer in seinem, und dann hat er so Träume und dann müssen die in den Traum rein und dann das zu pflanzen. Und dann kam so das THX-Logo und dann kam das Dolby Surround-Team. Was sei alles Key Grip. Naja, ich muss sagen, mir ist das Experiment, wie lange haben wir noch? Wir können abmodusen. Wir haben nicht gewusst, ob wir das so lange durchhalten. Das war die Folge Antenne Askerbaden. Wir können darüber sprechen. Ihr könnt entscheiden, was als nächstes zu Folge 2. Wir machen das auf jeden Fall alles. Ja, mal gucken, mal gucken. Es ist ja die Frage, wie viel das interessiert. Aber es gibt auf jeden Fall eine Menge Dinge zu sagen. Wir gehen jetzt erstmal in eine kleine Sommerpause, wir haben jetzt erstmal Urlaub und wir fliegen nach New York mal wieder. Und es wird wieder eine Folge auf dem YouTube-Ufo geben. Und folgt uns auf Instagram, Snapchat macht bloß niemand mehr, weil wir machen Stories. Wir machen Instagram Stories, so geil. Florian, ich führe euch durch unser Haus. Ich führe euch durch unser Haus. Du heisst atpommesruppel. Pommes-Ruppel auf Instagram. Ich heisse atestimantithios. Genau, wir sind unterwegs. Und das heisst, es kommen erstmal ein paar Wochen keine Folgen, ich bin danach auch nochmal alleine im Urlaub, das heisst erstmal schöne Sommerpause, geniesst den Sommer, hört mal ein paar alte Folgen an, lest ein paar Bücher, schaut euch ein paar Harry Potter Folgen an.
Schaut euch ein paar Harry Potter Filme an, ich finde wir haben viel darüber gesagt und ich meine, sorry wenn wir da jetzt nicht so on detail drin waren.
Wir sind nicht so mega drin, Herr der Ringe ist eher so mein Metier, aber Harry Potter ist auch ganz cool.
Deswegen demnächst, Antennaunland, viel Spaß damit.
Ansonsten macht's gut, schönen Sommer, bis dann.
Schönen Sommer, macht's gut, schönen Sommer, bis dann, wir haben ab.